>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Robert Casper:
Tonight, we are happy again
to feature the literary
organization Kundiman.
The organization founded in 2004
is dedicated to the creation,
cultivation, and promotion
of Asian American literature.
For more on the organization
you can visit www.kundiman.org.
And, now, I'm going
to get off the stage
and welcome Kundiman fellow
Gowri K. to tell us more
about the featured readers
and the setup of this program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Gowri K.: Good
evening, everyone.
>> Good evening.
>> Gowri K.: Thank you, Rob,
and to the Library of Congress,
to the Smithsonian APA Center,
and Lawrence Minbui Davis
[assumed spelling], and,
of course, to Kundiman for
inviting me to participate
in this program tonight.
I feel honored and privileged
to introduce tonight's featured
writers, and also converse
with them afterwards
about their craft.
And after we have a short
discussion, we'll open it
up to the audience for audience
Q and A. So, feel free to come
up with some questions
as the night goes
on to pose to our writers.
We'll start off hearing
the work of R. O. Kwon,
and later we will have a
reading by Hieu Minh Nguyen.
R. O. Kwon was born in South
Korea and has lived most
of her life in the
United States.
She is a national endowment
for the arts literature fellow,
and her writing has appeared
in the Guardian, Time, Vice,
Buzzfeed, Noon, Electric
Literature,
Asian American Literary
Review, and elsewhere.
She has received numerous
awards, including those
from Yaddo, MacDowell, the
Bread Loaf Writers' Conference,
the Steinbeck Center, and the
Norman Mailer Writers' Colony.
Kwon's first novel, The
Incendiaries, was published
in July of this year
by Riverhead.
The New York Times Book
Review said of her novel,
The Incendiaries is
about extremism, yes,
but it's for anyone who's ever
been captivated by another,
for anyone who has been on
either side of a relationship
that clearly has a subject
and object of obsession,
for anyone who's had
a brush with faith
or who's been fully bathed in
its teachings, for anyone afraid
of his or her own power.
Please welcome R. O. Kwon.
[ Applause ]
>> R. O. Kwon: Hi, hello.
Hi. I'm so glad and
excited to be here.
Thank you for coming, and thank
you to Library of Congress,
and thank you to Kundiman
and thank you to Lawrence.
I just -- this is so exciting.
Thank you.
I am going to read
from The Incendiaries.
It's my first novel and it's
about a Korean-American woman,
Phoebe Lin, who is pulled into
a radical group that turned
out to be a cult with
enigmatic ties to North Korea.
The cult eventually bombs
five U.S. abortion clinics,
healthcare clinics,
in the name of faith.
And when several bystanders
die, she disappears.
So, I worked on this
novel for 10 years,
which means I've had -- I've had
a lot of time to attend a lot
of parties, and dinner
parties, and thanksgivings,
and family gatherings at which
people ask what I'm doing,
what do I do?
And I say I write.
I'm working on a novel, and
they'd ask what it's about.
So, I would tell them pretty
much just what I told you right
now, and by far the most
common follow-up question,
including from family
members, has been,
is your novel autobiographical
[laughter], which I found
to be incredibly confusing
and funny and hard to answer.
Because I think they're
all asking
if I'm a domestic terrorist
or if I've been involved
in a violent cult, or if
I've blown up buildings.
A friend was just like,
you should just start saying
I'm no longer at liberty to talk
about this, but [laughter],
I haven't tried that yet.
We'll see.
So, short answer,
no, I have it blown
up any buildings, not just yet.
But, there is a longer possible
answer about what obsessions
and losses led to this book.
So, I thought I'd touch briefly
on those before reading
a little from it.
The novel does draw
on my own background,
as a formerly zealous
evangelical Christian,
until I was 17 and
stopped believing.
My entire life plan was
to become a preacher
or a missionary or maybe a
religious recluse in a cave.
I don't know, I hadn't really
thought out the details,
but I was excited about it.
I've long since left
the faith behind,
but I do often still find
the loss of it to be fresh,
as though it happened
maybe a few days ago.
And, perhaps as a result
of how different I am
from the God crazed girl
I once was, I'm fascinated
by the variety in
people's definitions
of good and of right.
In The Incendiaries, I was drawn
to bridging imaginative chasms
between rational and
fanatic worldviews.
And, in addition, I have distant
family members I've never met,
who live or lived, for all
I know, in North Korea,
and who I'll probably
never meet.
For a while, to try to fill that
hole in knowledge, that longing,
I kept reading accounts
of North Korea.
And, of course, what little
information that makes it out is
so incomplete, and
eventually I became interested
in exploring this gap itself.
But, in writing about
North Korea, I very much --
I didn't want to make any claims
about a place I've never
been able to visit,
and that so few people ever see.
Instead, even as I gave
a North Korean pass
to the novel's cult leader, John
Leal, I hoped to explore some
of the vast gaps in knowledge
and to dwell imaginatively
in that place of unknowing.
The book alternates between
three points of view,
that of Phoebe Lin, the woman
who falls into the cult,
John Leal, the cult leader, and
Will Kendall, who loves Phoebe
and opposes the cult to
much of what it represents.
I'll read a section from
each of their points of view
from the start of the book.
One, Will.
They'd have gathered on
a rooftop in Noxhurst
to watch the explosion.
Platt Hall, I think,
11 floors up.
I know his ego, and he'd
have picked the tallest point
he could.
So often, I've imagined
how they felt, waiting.
With six minutes
left, the slant light
of dusk reddened the high
old spires of the college,
the level gables of
its surrounding town.
They poured festive wine
into big-bellied glasses.
Hands shaking, they laughed.
She would sit apart from this
reveling group, cross-legged
on the roof's west ledge.
Three minutes to go, two, one.
The Phipps building fell.
Smoke plumed the breath of God.
Silence followed, then the
group's shouts of triumph.
Wine glasses clashed together,
flashing martial light.
He sang the first
bars of a Jejah psalm,
others soon joined in.
Carillon bells chimed, distant
birds blowing white, strewn,
like dandelion tufts,
an outsize wish.
It must have been then that
John Leal came to her side.
In his bare feet, he closed
his arm around her shoulders.
She flinched, looking up at him.
I can imagine how he'd
have tightened his hold,
telling her she'd done
well, though before long,
it would be time to act
again, to do a little more.
But, this is where I start
having trouble, Phoebe.
Buildings fell.
People died.
You once told me I hadn't
even tried to understand.
So, here I am, trying.
Two, John Leal.
Once John Leal left Noxhurst,
halfway through his last term
of college, he drifted until
he ended up in Yanji, China.
In this city, adjacent to
North Korea, he began working
with an activist group
that smuggled Korean refugees
toward asylum in Seoul.
He'd found his life's
work, he thought.
Instead, he was kidnapped
by North Korean agents,
spirited across the border,
and thrown into a prison
camp outside of Pyongyang.
In the stories he
later told the group,
he said the gulag
brutalities were bad enough,
but at least they'd
been expected.
What astonished him was the
allegiance his fellow inmates
showed toward the lunatic despot
whose policies had installed
them in their cells.
They'd been jailed because, oh,
they'd splashed a drop of tea
on his newsprint portrait.
A neighbor claimed to have
overheard them whistling a South
Korean pop song.
Punished for absurdities,
they still maintained
that the beloved sovereign,
a divine being, couldn't
be to blame.
At first, he assumed
this was lip service,
the prisoners afraid
to say otherwise.
But then, he thought of the
refugees he'd met in Yanji,
how they talked of loving
the god they'd fled.
They attributed the
regime's troubles to anyone
but the sole person in charge.
A month into John
Leal's time in the gulag,
prison guards held an
optional foot race,
the prize a framed
icon of the despot.
In the confusion, those
who fell were trampled.
One child died of
a broken spine.
Through howls of pain, he
shouted hosannahs for his lord.
They weren't lying,
the poor fools.
They believed in the man as one
might believe in Jesus Christ.
Some people needed leading.
In or out of the gulag,
they craved faith.
But think if the tyrant
had been as upright
as his disciples
trusted him to be.
The heights he'd have
achieved, if he loved them, if,
John Leal thought,
until his idea began.
Three, Phoebe.
I hoped I'd be a piano
genius, Phoebe told the group,
in the first Jejah
confession she tried giving.
But I didn't just
wait, she said.
I expected, no, I
wanted to work for it.
I spilled time into the piano
as I'd have put cash in a bank.
I saw full concert
halls in the future,
solo recitals, front-page
plaudits.
I practiced Liszt while
imagined spotlights gilded the
living room.
Recollection is half
invention, but it feels
as though I spent my
entire childhood training
to prove I was the significant
pianist I believed I'd be.
So, I piled up trophies.
It wasn't enough.
The teacher flicked my hands
with a rod each time I
didn't hit the right note,
but I didn't mind.
My ambition outstripped his.
Let my hands swell.
I could use the extra span.
Bright-knuckled, I tried again.
The months ticked
past, then years.
I kept lists of rivals.
I indexed others'
exploits by age.
Kiehl, at five, had
given his first recital
to the Danish king.
Ohri, 11, debuted at
Carnegie Hall; Liu, 15.
One night, my teacher called
Libich's Etude Number Five the
most challenging piece
a soloist might attempt.
It's eluded the finest
pianists, he said.
I rushed to find
the Etude score.
I learned it alone, in secret.
I memorized Libich's
high trills.
I flailed through
wild ostinatos.
Once, at the table, my mother
asked what I was smiling about.
Haejin, she said.
I blinked, Libich
vibrating in my head.
I don't. She laughed.
It's all right, she said.
I ate while she peeled
a white peach.
The skin dropped
in a single coil.
She picked it up,
holding it to the light.
Such a rich hue, she said.
It flushed pink, backlit; I
nodded, then she put it down.
I could tell she wished to
talk, but I was lost in trills.
I pushed a last peach
slice in my mouth,
and I went back to the piano.
Until then, nothing I played had
evoked the orphic singing I knew
to be possible.
It was an ideal I lacked
the skill to bring to life.
Each first-place
prize marked a point
when I had let the music down.
With Libich, I failed less.
His Etude asked so much
of me that, at times,
I'd forget I had an I.
I should have learned,
from this, that playing had
to be birthed in a
place without ego,
in which I didn't exist except
as the living conduit,
Libich's medium.
But then, when I showed the
teacher what I could do,
he was astonished.
I'd achieved more than
he'd hoped, he said.
He switched the piece in
for the next competition,
a city-level open.
I was driven to the
recital hall.
The sun fell on my hands as
I practiced Libich again,
fingers dancing across my legs.
Spotlit, I listened to
the traffic sing my name.
The lax blue of L.A.,
heat-rippled, veiled
the horizon.
Like curtains, I
thought, poised to rise.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Gowri K.: Thank
you [inaudible].
Next, we'll hear from
Hieu Minh Nguyen,
a queer Vietnamese-American poet
and performer based
out of Minneapolis.
He was the recipient of a 2017
NEA Fellowship for poetry,
a Kundiman fellow, a poetry
editor for Muzzle Magazine,
and an MFA candidate at
Warren Wilson College.
His work has appeared in PBS
News Hour, Poetry Magazine,
Gulf Coast, Buzzfeed,
Poetry London,
Indiana Review, and more.
His debut collection of
poetry, This Way to the Sugar,
published by Write
Bloody Publishing in 2014,
was named a finalist for both
the Lambda Literary Award
and the Minnesota Book Award.
And his second collection of
poetry, Not Here, was published
by Coffeehouse Press
in April of this year.
This year, he was also
named one of five recipients
of the Ruth Lilly and Dorothy
Sergeant Roseburg Poetry
Fellowship Award.
About Hieu's work, Ocean Vuong
has said, his work is so tight,
searing, and unabashedly
sharp and full at once.
His poems turn me into
a horizontal entity.
Reading them, I have
to lie down [laughter].
They remind me of gravity,
how it pins me to the world
without ever touching me.
Hieu's work is like
that, a kind of force,
or better yet, a
force of kindness.
Please welcome Hieu Minh Nguyen.
[ Applause ]
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen: Thank
you all so much for having me.
Thank you to Lawrence Min
and thank you [inaudible]
for your beautiful reading.
I am really bad at like banter,
so I'm not going to do it much.
So, I'm not going to talk to
you all, because I hate you.
See, that's what happens, right?
I just insult the audience.
So, I prepared a little
introduction, if I can find it.
Okay, there it is.
First, before I talk
about anything else,
let me talk about the
joys of online dating.
I am an expert at
the brief, efficient,
economical conversation.
Usually people think I'm
joking when I asked them
about their retirement plan,
about their credit score,
about their potential IRS
audit risk, but I'm not.
Lately, when a new suitor
asks me how I'm doing,
I respond with good, despite
the world being on fire.
Here, I use the trick
of melodrama in order
to gauge the reaction of
my potential husbands.
Their responses usually
fluctuate
between what are you
talking about and,
yeah, I know what you mean.
It's is a small trick I use
to inform myself to whether
or not the person I am talking
to has been paying attention
to the atrocities happening
in the world around us.
I use fire to find a companion
in misery, though it's difficult
to be sure if the boy and I
are staring at the same fire.
And, if we are, who do
we blame for the flames?
And, was there ever a time
where the world wasn't on fire?
As soon as I became
proficient in English,
my mother started asking me
to translate the morning --
the morning news to her.
She wanted to participate
with the world.
Some things were easy.
I could explain house fires.
I could explain high-speed
chases.
I could even stumble my way
through political scandals.
But, remember, as
a kindergartner,
I had to learn how to study
the atrocities of the world
and interpret them, not only
into language, but logic.
Nine 11 happened when I was 10.
Columbine happened
when I was eight.
Matthew Shepard was
murdered when I was seven.
Even now, I can hear
my mom saying,
[speaking foreign language],
who, who would do that?
Who could do that?
Why? Why would they do that?
Why would they do
that to that boy?
Gay? Gay? What does that mean?
Oh, okay.
It's important to mention the
only time my mother speaks
in English is when I
make her speak in a poem.
So she says, get out,
says, leave but it's me,
my voice, that slams the door.
The only way out is through
the opening of her mouth.
The only way towards
salvation is forgiveness,
the aunts would say, licking
their thumbs across my forehead.
Sure, the only mask I own
is humming on my face.
I want to study the
mechanics of leaving.
Go. Go. Go, so I can see.
Slow so I can watch
everything fade to water.
I think it was Sappho who said,
I long and seek after but,
of course, that's not what
she said, not exactly.
If things happen the
way they are supposed
to my mother will die before me.
My mother, who, by then,
will love me will die.
will hopefully be happy,
will walk without pain from
this life into the next, and I,
her only son, her
writer son will stay
to translate her
life into English.
Any adjective can be true
if you cry hard enough.
I can lie and say I
haven't written the poem,
haven't buried her over
and over at my desk,
haven't described
the ash of her body.
I throw a fistful of sand in
the air and pretend to weep.
I write the poem.
I fill my lungs with English.
I number her skin with English.
I English the light
she walks into.
I kill her just to
raise her from the dead.
I anticipate this grief by
exhausting it with music.
I pry open the casket.
I make her twirl in the center.
Question. Who here hates
the word moist [laughter]?
Can I see a show of hands?
Who like -- who here just like
absolutely hates that word?
All right, okay.
So, I wrote a poem.
It's called In Defense
of Moist [laughter].
Most moan, voice their disdain
for the motion their
mouth makes.
The sound whining in their ears,
chalking up their hate
to just pure phonics.
Moist. Moist.
I just hate -- it
just sounds gross.
It makes everything
sound sexual,
even things that aren't
supposed to be sexual.
Moist towelette.
Moist sponge.
Moist eviction notice.
Moist hoisting oysters
to your lips,
giving you no choice
but to swallow.
Some have even petitioned
to have the word removed
from the dictionary
completely, but imagine a world
where you eat damp cake or
someone says -- or someone says,
mmm [phonetic], these
cookies are wet.
What would you do
then [laughter]?
Maybe you can't handle it.
Maybe it's too precise a word.
Your body swelling with
salt and it's mentioned.
Maybe you sweat too much
and you're embarrassed
at how the word makes
even your mouth perspire.
Maybe you hate how the
word clings, like spinach
to your teeth, and
I can't blame you.
I understand what it's
like to hate something
for no good reason, other
than for the way it sounds.
I know what it's like to
want to replace the words
that embarrass you, an
entire language really.
In Vietnamese there's only
one word I know for mother.
Only one word I know for son,
[speaking foreign language].
Not like swindle, but
the sound a gong makes
when muffled by water.
Vietnamese demands precision.
If said in the wrong tone,
son could mean stay,
could mean remain.
My tongue, a pend -- my
tongue a pendulum swinging
between what is here
and what isn't.
When what's left of this
language gets stuck in my teeth,
the only synonyms I can
find are in English.
English, a river my
mother cannot swim across,
rising from each attempt
soaked in embarrassment.
My tongue, a stone I
tried to skip across.
My accent, a crumbling monument.
[Speaking foreign language].
What will happen when there's
nothing left to replace?
What will happen when she
can no longer understand me?
Is there a word for that?
Is it in English?
So, there is -- so, I go
to Warren Wilson
College for my MFA.
And, in the summertime, during
the residency, there is --
there is this softball
game that takes place
between fiction writers and
poets, right [laughter].
And, I want to say
like in the history,
in like the 100-year history
of the program, it hasn't been
around that long, but
the poets have won may be
like two times [laughter].
Like, this past summer
we lost 70 to 10.
But, like, I also want
to confront the idea
that like poets are
like passive and weak.
And, so, I wrote this poem.
Don't be mistaken.
It wasn't too long ago when
my friends and I walked
with master locks
around our knuckles,
eager to dare each
oncoming car to flinch.
Listen, if I've learned
anything,
it's that every play fight
will turn into a real fight
if you touch the face.
And we were ready, honey-eyed
bastards waiting for any graze
or slight breeze to
give us permission.
Pacing the same mile radius,
our fists seething with mud.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying I'm
a good fighter.
I'm just saying I was never
afraid to get my ass beat
in the name of not running.
We fought everywhere, in
the park, in basements,
silently in school bathrooms
so no one would break it up.
For a long time there
was one rule I live by.
If they jump in,
I'm jumping in, too.
The last flight I
got into it was
because Jordan [assumed
spelling] called me a faggot,
his mouth.
Afterwards, we laid in the
grass panting, my ears bleeding,
his mouth swollen and beautiful.
And sure, I left that place
and don't plan on going back.
And sure, these days the friends
I have eat brunch, fly to places
like Vermont to write poems near
streams while contemplating the
lifecycles of bees.
Or, cry when they think about
the majesty of elephants.
But, don't be confused.
They may be washed and
usually in bed before 10,
but my friends now are just like
my friends then, always ready,
a legion of faggots flushed out
and shining prepared
for anything.
And sure, this can be an analogy
for the radius of our lives,
how we will all return
to where we started.
Or, maybe, this is an
analogy for those headlines,
poets fight oppression
with words,
going on about the strength it
takes to make art in the face
of those who'd want to
harm us, like Artemis,
and a crew who'd hunt the
men she'd turned into deer.
Or, maybe, I'm just
saying it's hunted
that know best how to hunt.
Or, maybe, there's an idea
here that has nothing to do
with blood, but everything to
do with the animal inside us,
a singular creature, looking
for a shape, a herd, a pack,
a pride, to beckon our
teeth from the gums.
Or, maybe, I'm just saying that
my friends will kick your ass.
No, not metaphorically, not
with our words, though probably,
but with our rings on, like
the bees who only swarm
when provoked, or the
elephants who will rush
to the aid of their own.
My friends will stomp you.
And sure, that was a simile.
Sure, that was a threat.
That was me saying if they
jump in, I'm jumping in, too.
[ Applause ]
Standing in front of a mirror,
my mother tells me she is ugly,
says the medication
is making her fat.
I laugh and walk
her back to the bed.
My mother tells me she is ugly
in the voice she
says -- okay, sorry.
Standing in front of a mirror,
my mother tells me she is ugly,
says the medication
is making her fat.
I laugh and walk
her back to bed.
My mother tells me she is ugly
in the same voice she used
to say, no woman could love
you and I watch her pull
at her body and it is mine.
My heavy breasts.
My disappointing shape.
She asks for a bowl of plain
broth and it becomes the cup
of vinegar she would
pour down my throat.
Every day after school,
I would kneel before her.
I would remove my clothes and
ask her to mark the progress.
It's important that I
mention, I truly wanted
to be beautiful for her.
In my dreams I am thin, and
if not thin, something better.
I tell my mother she is still
beautiful and she laughs.
The room fills with flies.
They gather in the
shape of a small boy.
They lead her back
to the mirror,
but my reflection
is still there.
Ode to the pubic hair
stuck in my throat.
O diligent survivor clinging
to the edge of a chasm.
Little tickle.
Little wire picking open the
doors, illuminating the corners
of my body I did not know
could swell with touch.
Bless touch, I guess,
its round noise.
O little brown figure
coiling in the middle
of that soft pink alley.
How lonely it must be
to come from desire
but end where light ends.
Son of the floorless
prayer, son of the O horizon,
remind me what it's
like to speak
without a white man
flickering in my throat.
O small equator, making every
story a ruined portrait.
Bless the fault line
beyond my reach.
Little fracture in my speech.
Little secret I keep
trying to cough up
but instead cause my mother
to raise her small
hands to my forehead.
[Speaking foreign language].
Bless also my mother,
her perfect temperature,
her concern the only
language we have to say sorry.
Bless language, its
impossible walls,
its flexible agony a thin
line I keep tripping over.
O little thread, undoing the
hem of my body, but wait,
bless also my body, how
it rejects the unfamiliar,
convulsing, conversing with
itself, excising, evicting,
cutting down the rope
bridge, rolling the debris
into a question mark
on my tongue.
I have a few more
poems to share,
and then I will run out of here.
I'm going to read
a little sonnet.
Maybe a bit dramatic, but I
like candles with my breakfasts,
wear a white gown around
the house like a virgin.
Right or wrong, forgive me.
No one in this town
knows forgiveness.
Miles from the limits, if
I squint there's Orion.
If heaven exists, I will
be there in a minute
to hop the pearly gates,
a ghost felon to find him.
Of blood, of mud, of
wisemen, who am I now
after all these years
without him.
Boy, widow, barbarian,
tapping hornets in my big grin.
He'll fear who I've been since.
I wake up each morning from
all these strange dreams
where I'm drowning.
As boys, your father fed us
fresh meat from the lake,
taught us to spit bones into the
fire, handed us each a knife,
told us to enter the woods and
return with something dead.
And when we returned
with nothing
but our bodies, he
assumed he failed.
But, what did he know about
death that we couldn't learn,
will learn from our hands.
And because you aren't
here, won't ever, again,
be here to cover my mouth, I'll
confess, out loud, my love,
so maybe perhaps, you
will hear me and join me,
here where the sun is
sweet against the water.
And because I love you,
I will gut this distance
with nostalgia, because
grief can taste of sugar
if you run your tongue
along the right edge,
so let me call your
name, or rather mouth it,
like when we watched your father
strike a cleaver into the neck
of a hawk and fell silent, not
because of the blood but rather
for the way the hawk's
severed body took flight,
leaving behind its head, a
scarlet burden in the soil.
And I wish so badly, I was
brave enough then, to keep it,
to tuck it beneath my tongue
for these twenty years.
And because darling, before I
came alive, I watched the world
without knowing what to look
for, but I swear, it was there,
again, above the tall grass,
the headless hawk still
alive, still somehow flying.
So, the last poem
I'm going to read.
It's -- so, I've done like --
I've had a lot of weird jobs.
I was like a pizza delivery
boy, and then also I was also,
with a bunch of my friends,
we used to dance on the corner
with like pizza signs, and we
had choreography and everything.
And I have my friend,
Jeremy [assumed spelling],
who was my best friend
in high school.
And, yeah, so, the next
book I'm working on is a lot
about the east side of St.
Paul, which is where I grew up,
and how it is, though it is
technically part of a city,
it feels very isolated
from the rest of the city,
and oftentimes functions
as its own small town.
And, so, I'm writing a lot
about the people I grew up with.
Of all the things
I've tried to do,
I was probably worst
at selling weed.
Robbed weekly.
Used too much of my
own product [laughter].
Cut each bag with
a dash of oregano.
Sorry. But then I
have to consider
that summer Maddie
[assumed spelling] asked me
to help him boost cars.
His dad called me a liability,
too paranoid to be lookout,
too shaky to use a Slim Jim,
didn't even know
how to drive stick.
Oh yeah, let's not forget
that time Moe [assumed
spelling] almost lost an arm
after I convinced him to pay
me 20 bucks to stitch his wound
with fishing line instead
of going to the hospital.
Or, that time I almost
convinced --
I convinced Aaliyah [assumed
spelling] to let me tattoo
across on her ankle with a
safety pin and a ballpoint.
And then there's that --
and then there's that
time I swiped [inaudible]
from Carl Maggie's [assumed
spelling] locker and tried
to set myself straight
by becoming of violinist.
But, of course, the
noise complaints.
The neighbors banging the
portraits off the walls.
The boys talking shit, calling
me prodigy, fancy chink.
And I wonder if you're
still having a good laugh.
Like when they found out
I wanted to be a poet,
so they glued roses and
violets to the hood of my Kia.
And so maybe I wanted, for the
first time, to prove them wrong,
prove I didn't belong there.
And so maybe I made new friends,
friends who wrote poems,
who sat around talking about
poems, who went to school
to study poems, and lived
in off-campus apartments
where I crashed on nights I got
too fucked up on white boy drugs
to drive back to the east side,
where even without me
the [inaudible] glow
of junkers trace the block
where Mandy [assumed spelling],
three years sober, tucks
the kids into the bed,
where Lee [assumed
spelling], first in his class,
spray paints the fleet
of stolen bikes gold,
where Andrew [assumed
spelling] stands
in the kitchen reading
the Bible in the dim light
from the microwave, where Nikki
[assumed spelling], years later,
coming home after
a double at Champs,
calls to wish me
a happy birthday.
And I am, of course,
too busy to answer,
somewhere in a different
time zone,
at a swanky party celebrating
a man I do not know,
who just won an award for
a book I have not read.
And the woman who smells of
citrus, who's been raving
to me all night about how
much she admires my work,
excuses herself to
use the bathroom,
leaving in the seat beside
me her open purse [laughter].
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Gowri K.: Thank you, Hieu.
Reese, can I invite you back
up to the stage as well.
If you'd like to give
a round of applause
for both of our authors.
[ Applause ]
So, we'll start off with a
bit of discussion up here.
And then, as I mentioned
earlier, we'll open it
up for audience Q and
A. so, please think
about any questions
you might have
for our two writers
this evening.
It's lovely to meet
both of you today.
>> R. O. Kwon: Same as you.
>> Gowri K.: Thank you for
coming to D.C. I'm really happy
to get to have this conversation
with you both as well.
The first question I have for
you is actually a question
that I also posed to a couple
of writers back in May.
It was another event
co-sponsored by Kundiman.
It was at the Folger Shakespeare
Library around the corner.
And that night the featured
writers were Kava Akubar
[assumed spelling] and Kazam
Ali [assumed spelling].
And I asked them this question.
I would be very interested to
hear your responses as well.
I initially just referred
to Bhanu Kapil's book,
The Vertical Interrogation
of Strangers.
Which, if you're familiar with
it, every poem takes its title
from a question, and many
of the questions repeat
themselves throughout the book.
And one of many questions
she poses and returns to in
that book is the following.
What are the consequences
of silence?
Now, both of you simultaneously
and intersectionally
embody various identities.
And, for myself, when I
talk about identities,
I also like to substitute
terms like truths
and lived experienced,
so we don't get confused
by what we mean when
we say identities.
So, based on all of that,
I would ask how you might
answer Bhanu Kapil's question
for your work, for what you may
be using your own writing for,
your own lives, for the people
you may be reaching out to
with your words, what are
the consequences of silence?
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen:
That's a good question.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible ]
I am going to try to even -- I'm
going to attempt to answer it.
But, it is like a really --
it's -- I'm living a lot of,
there's not just
one consequence.
I think there's a
lot of consequences.
But, if you're talking
about like the self, right,
like if you don't -- it
just means like what happens
when you don't speak
up for yourself, right?
How do you -- just all the
ways that you can't advocate
for yourself and what
do you allow when you --
When you don't speak up.
And I think it's also like a --
I'm going to -- I'm going to
argue with myself for a second.
I think it's also like what --
when I say like what
are you allowing?
It sounds like I'm
placing blame on the person
that isn't speaking up.
But, like we have to
consider all the --
all the things that like
that's keeping that person
from not speaking up, and it's
keeping that person silent.
So, I think -- I don't blame
people for not speaking
up sometimes, because
it's like hard.
And it also can be -- I
think I turned it off.
>> There it goes.
You got it.
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen: All
right, hey [laughter].
I'm not going to repeat
myself [laughter].
But, yeah, I think
that's one [inaudible].
>> Gowri K.: That's
a great answer.
>> R. O. Kwon: Yeah, that's a
-- that's a gigantic question.
Good question.
Let's see.
Maybe I -- maybe I'll answer
that just in terms of,
because people so often ask --
a question that I
get asked a lot,
I'm sure you get asked a lot,
is who are you writing for?
And my truthful stock answer
is that I'm writing for myself,
because when I write I find
it so absorbing that I can't,
I really can't think about
any sort of external audience.
And, so, I go into some sort
of place where there's just me
and the language and syllables.
I'm just trying to get things
down to be as good and true
as I can, and there's
no one else there.
When I step back from
that, and when I think
about what that means,
I feel as though in
a lot of ways that in
and of itself is a political
act, because that means
that I'm centering myself
as a reader, and that means
that I'm centering
people like me.
And the more people are like
me the more they're going
to understand some of the
references, some of the --
some of the illusions.
And, so, for instance, an
example I often give is
that there's a -- Phoebe Lin,
one of the [inaudible]
Korean-American,
and her mother only
ever called [inaudible]
and she never calls her Phoebe.
And some people,
multiple people asked,
do you want to explain
that in the text?
Do you want to say,
[inaudible] is a Korean name?
And I was just like, absolutely
fucking not, man [laughter].
Because any Asian-American
reader I can think
of would understand
that's her Korean name
and that's what her
family calls her,
and I shouldn't have to explain
that for anybody any more
than -- any more than people who
have ever explained to me what
on earth all those
[inaudible] terms are.
And, so, I think -- I think in
terms of who is being centered
as the reader, and so
I've been asked by --
people have asked along
the way like, do you think
about white men when you write?
It's a question I've gotten.
And, honestly, I don't
very much [laughter].
Yeah.
>> Gowri K.: Thank you both for
your very thoughtful answers.
And, also, the ways in which
you both bring up the politics
of [inaudible] responses
to that question
and the politics
of being able to
speak out and feeling even
limited amount of safety or lack
of real material, physical
violence or consequences,
and how so many people are
stepping passed that and facing
that when they do speak up.
My second question I'm going
to follow is from the first,
but comes at it from the
sort of opposite angle.
And rather than asking about the
consequences of silence here,
I want to know what you
find to be the consequences
of actually speaking your
truth or truths, particularly
as your work gains more and
more exposure nationally,
internationally?
I think frequently, particularly
in different communities,
whether they be identity-based
communities
or social justice-oriented
communities,
we tend to commend artists and
celebrate artists for
doing the hard work
of liberating their
traumas into an artform.
I always personally wonder about
the other side of that equation.
And namely, what are the
consequences for that artist,
whether in ways that they may
now have to relate to family,
friends, community, or other
spaces or groups of people?
So there, again,
what I would ask is,
what are the consequences then
when you do speak, and certainly
with a lot of the topics
and experiences that the two
of you have addressed
in your books?
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen: We were
talking about this earlier
in a small group discussion, I
think one of the consequences is
that people then take your
narrative and your story
as like the bee story, right?
Like, you're supposed
to represent everybody,
and that you're supposed
to -- and it's --
there's like this responsibility
to get it right, right?
Because, you know,
Asian-American literature
has only existed
for like so long, right?
And, so, it's not that there is
-- I'm trying [inaudible] but,
like because there aren't that
many models out there, right,
like we are expected to be
the model, or we are expected
to speak for multiple people,
and we're just like speaking
about ourselves and our
own experiences, right?
Sometimes not even,
right, fiction, you know.
Yeah.
>> R. O. Kwon: I think maybe
one way to answer that is,
so pretty much since December
my writing [inaudible] in a lot
of ways and I've been very
involved in sort of preparing
for my book to come out, it
just came out last month,
and what's happened with that is
for the last eight months I wake
in the morning, I realize,
and every morning I'm worried
about who I might have
pissed off or disappointed.
And it's just like I don't even
know who, like I don't know who,
like maybe someone on Twitter,
or somebody who I work with,
or just somebody out
there might be mad at me.
And I've been thinking
about that.
And I was talking to a friend,
who has published many books,
and he's also a writer,
he's a writer
of color, and he was just like,
I'm afraid about that all
the time, too, and, you know,
I've been doing this for years.
And he was like, you're
actually right to be afraid
because you are currently a
representative of your people.
Like people look at
you and [inaudible]
about Korean-Americans.
And you are walking around
and they'll be like, oh okay,
I know about Korean-Americans
because of something you said.
And, so, I've been thinking
about that and what that means.
But, on the other hand,
I think when I'm writing,
and [inaudible] in the
small group discussion,
when I'm writing and when I'm
engaging with the fiction,
there's, again, no space for any
of this and I just have to --
I'm only writing well if
I'm digging for my truths.
Again, I also [inaudible]
with my truths
and with what I'm trying to get
on the page, and when I'm doing
that there's no space to
worry about what anyone
else is going to think
and I just have to --
and I feel as though
maybe that burrowing
and that specificity is in
itself being responsible,
or as responsible as I can be.
>> Gowri K.: Yeah, and I
thank you, too, for bringing
up the issue, both of you,
of representation and how
when there's already
[inaudible] representation,
then how much higher the
pedestal is, so to speak,
that you are then placed
on as the representative
of all Asian-Americans.
And I think, also, when we
look at that, and I guess some
of what I have seen
in my own community,
is how there can be a lot of
[inaudible] community criticism.
You know, you represent us and,
even though you don't
represent all of us,
you mentioned these
things in your book,
and they are real things.
And, so, there can be that sort
of intercommunity kind of debate
and critique that
happens as well.
We've started getting
into just the concept
of Asian-American literature
and Asian-American writers,
and certainly tonight's
event is part
of the Asian-American
Literature Today series.
So, I would like to hear both
of your thoughts on some topics
that I would say
fall under the topic
of Asian-American
literature today.
So, sort of multiple-choice
items.
You may choose from them.
You may choose all
of the following
if you so delight in them.
Asian-American writers
you're excited about,
whether they are people who've
been publishing or performing
for years, or maybe
more emerging voices.
Asian-American writers
who have mentored
and supported your development
that you would like to shout out
and [inaudible] boost for all
of the lovely people here.
And, also, just any thoughts
you would want to share
on the contemporary U.S.
Asian-American literary
community, or communities.
[ Laughter ]
>> R. O. Kwon: Well,
I can start on this.
So, my book came out in July.
And this summer there
have been so many debuts
by Asian-American women,
and it's been so exciting.
There are so many
that, for a while,
I was just actually keep
a stack of them by my --
by my own desk, because they
made me happy to look at them.
And, so, some of the books
that have come out are by --
there's a book by Lucy
Tan [assumed spelling],
there's [inaudible].
There's Crystal Hana
Kim [assumed spelling].
There's, let's see, [inaudible].
I mean, I'm not listing
everybody,
Lilian Le [assumed spelling].
It's just -- it's been a -- it's
like -- it's just been like a,
I mean relatively
speaking, right,
compared to what
we've had before,
it feels like an explosion.
And, so, that's been
really exciting.
And in terms of mentors,
I don't know, so many.
But, I feel as though like
a few -- like, let's see,
[inaudible] champions
of other writers
and Asian-American writers.
And I also, you know --
I'm also very excited about
and feel indebted to the work
that the ALR have been doing
with Lawrence and me
and with [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
At like multiple readings
people have asked,
do all of you Asian
writers know one another?
[Inaudible], I think in, as
offensive a way as that sounds,
but because people are so
supportive of one another
on social media and because
people are always shouting one
another out,
and I feel as though
there is something to --
I don't know, I just feel the
community is very supportive
in a way that I --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen: So,
[inaudible] collection,
If They Come for Us, just
came out in early August.
And that book is
one of the books
that I carry with me a lot.
And she is also doing a lot
of really incredible work,
not just only in poetry,
but like she is --
she is writing a series
for HBO, and she is --
she's just like a [inaudible].
And I also read Lucy Tan's
book this summer, too,
and I really loved it.
And mentors.
One of my mentors, [inaudible].
Just, he is a poet and also
writes fiction as well.
And I think a shout out to
also Joseph Gatsby [assumed
spelling], who is one of
the cofounders of Kundiman.
And, yeah.
>> Gowri K.: Thank
you [laughter].
I'm going to ask one more
question and then we'll open it
up to the audience
for questions as well.
And I think someone
will bring a microphone
around to the audience folks
who have something to ask.
So, now you both, you each
published one or more books.
A lot of people in the
room today are writers
at various stages
of their careers.
And, so, I wanted
to ask, how are each
of you approaching the writing
process differently the second
or third time around now?
And, are there things you
learned through writing
and publishing your
previous books
that you think informs
your approach
to writing the current
material you're working on,
future publications?
And I think there, too, I
personally would be interested
in hearing, not just about,
you know, the writing process
and the craft, but things that
you may say you've learned
that inform you in terms
just the publishing process,
or book touring, or, you
know, what sort of happens
as your career stands spans more
and more publications
in the years?
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen:
One of the things
that I have been learning, a
lesson that I keep with me,
is that I don't have
to explain myself.
I think like, you know,
coming from all these
intersectional marginalized
identities, like one of the
things that I felt the need
to do is like defend myself.
And, oftentimes, that looks
like explaining who I am
and explaining, and it comes
with this idea that like
if people know I am human
then they will accept me.
But, then that's like also you
are pandering to these people
who haven't treated you well
in the first place, right?
Like, you're pandering to like
people in position of power
and not just doing
the work, right?
I think, -- so, yeah,
so like I am learning
to like not feel the need
explain who I am and --
I think we were talking
about it earlier,
like asking for empathy, because
that's not what we're doing,
right?
That's not what we're --
I'm not asking for pity.
I'm not asking to be considered.
I'm just trying to make my own
space, if that makes sense.
>> Gowri K.: Absolutely.
>> R. O. Kwon: So,
with my first book,
I spent the first two years
rewriting the first 20 pages
over and over and over again
every day, the [inaudible].
And then I threw it all away and
then I started all over again.
So, I learned from
that to not do
that [inaudible],
never, ever do that.
I just -- I had this idea
that I needed the
sentences to be perfect,
to be exactly right.
And I had this metaphor in
mind, and the metaphor was,
you need a solid
foundation to build a house.
And then, at the end of
those two years, belatedly,
I realized it was
the worst metaphor,
because you can't put -- you
can't put in a foundation
if you don't know what
the house looks like.
And, so -- and, so, with this
new book I've been trying --
my new novel I've been trying,
I've been working on
it for maybe two years,
and I've been trying to speed
through as many drafts as I can
to try to subvert my own
obsession with syllables,
with language, with
punctuation, frankly.
And I've been handwriting, I've
been doing all kinds of things
to try to get through
it quickly.
But, I don't -- I mean, the book
is such a -- it's such a like --
it's just sort of a [inaudible]
I have no idea what
it is and I feel
as though I've forgotten
how to write.
So, I'm not sure that
this method is any better.
We'll see [laughter].
[Inaudible] a while from now,
we'll see, like eight years.
I don't know.
I'm just hoping like six years,
I'm hoping this book
will take six years.
It sounds like a really nice,
short winter [laughter]
compared to 10.
In terms of what I -- one
thing I think I've learned,
[inaudible] the other
day, I am not --
I don't regret a single
thing I insisted for.
I mean, I insisted
on for my book.
I don't regret a single thing
I insisted on in terms of,
I don't even know,
in terms of --
in terms of like a single
mark or punctuation,
in terms of never, ever tell
[inaudible] I mean Korean words
or, you know, or French
words or anything.
And I think I learned from that,
that people just aren't going
to get as mad at me
as I think they will.
I feel as though like
every time I insist
on something I'm just worried
people will get incredibly
offended and they'll
like cut off all --
like I keep getting worried
that people will cancel all the
contracts or like never want
to talk to me again
or all these things.
And nobody will ever, people
have said this and it's true,
nobody cares about my book.
Nobody ever cared
about my book as much
as I did, not even my mother.
And, so, [inaudible] more
of a consequence to me,
which truly like there
are points when I said --
when like -- when
like I've said things
like I cannot change this
semi-colon to an em-dash,
it would actually
ruin the integrity
of the entire book
[laughter], [inaudible].
And I felt that way and
I'm glad that I stuck
by what I believed in,
even if I was afraid
that everyone would
be mad at me.
People just aren't going
to get that mad at you,
I think is what -- is what
I took away, probably,
I don't know, maybe,
who know [laughter].
>> Gowri K.: I have you -- I
know, so dramatic [laughter].
Stop the bus.
I have another answer,
because you were talking
about obsessions, right?
And one of the things
that I learned
when writing my second book,
right, is that like I had --
I felt early on that I can't
write about the same things.
I can't write about the same
subjects that I did in my --
in my first book,
because like, you know,
people want to hear
something else.
People want to see
that I moved on, right?
Like, so it's like learning
that like your obsessions
can be your obsessions,
that you can write about
the same thing forever.
It's like okay, right?
Like if you have --
like if you want to --
if you want to write -- if I
want to write about this cup
for the rest of my life, I'm
going to write about this cup.
It's just like about like
how you approach it, right?
And like -- yeah, but like
seeing things differently,
and like that is also, yeah,
obsessed over this
and it's okay.
Yeah.
>> Gowri K.: I feel like
one of the themes in both
of your responses to that
question kind of goes
around giving yourself
permission to do certain things,
to say certain things,
to take up space, take up
space of opinion and
integrity of your own work.
Thank you both so much for your
answers to all my questions.
[ Applause ]
Anne [assumed spelling]
is going to come
around with a wireless mic.
If you could just raise your
hand if you have a question
for either one of our
authors, or you can pose it
to both authors together.
And after we do our Q
and A we will conclude
with a book signing.
>> Hello. Okay.
So, first of all, this
is so cool [inaudible].
It's really interesting
to hear [inaudible].
So, my question is
for Hieu actually.
So, for part of my senior
project I publish month
[inaudible] journal for
women online [inaudible].
And I was wondering if
you've ever experienced
with [inaudible] and
what was your experience?
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen:
Yeah, of course.
I'm going to be honest.
Okay, so [laughter], I
always thought like haiku is
like the easy form, right?
Like if I had to -- if
I had an assignment due
and like I don't think I could
even write one more poem,
this is going to be the haiku.
But, also, like seeing
how much care that people
who take haiku seriously, right?
Like, and like what
it can do in that --
in those restrictions, right?
And like seeing how other
people navigate that form is
like really inspiring to me.
I feel like haiku won't
let me come back to it,
because like I disrespected
it [laughter].
So, I'm like still asking
for forgiveness, you know.
But, it is something that I --
You know, have learned to
take very seriously and not
like something that I am going
to do because I think it's easy,
right, because it's not.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Thank you so much.
Just because there's a
lot of laughter in here,
I'm just wondering if you could
talk about the roles of laughter
and or humor, both in
your writing process,
when you [inaudible] people,
and your own experience
of like reading and writing
your various forms that you do.
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen: I think
of humor as a way to kind
of ask people to
trust me, right?
And that --
If I can't get you to
laugh with me, right,
like then I probably
can't get you to like care
about anything else I'm saying.
Yeah, and that's the way I
take the role of humor is.
>> R. O. Kwon: I also think --
I feel as though it
would just feel so false
to write a whole
book that left off
at either end of the spectrum.
If you're a purely comic
writer or purely tragic,
that just feels so -- it
doesn't feel like my --
at least my experience
of the world.
I also feel as though the two --
the two really adapt to
one another and it's often
in the most tragic moments that
like [inaudible] like a dash
of comedy can make
things even more powerful.
I don't know if you read Alice
Elliott Dark's In the Gloaming.
This is a lovely short story,
but there's this
joke at the end.
And I remember I was
reading that story,
and I made the mistake of
reading that story in a cafe,
and like at the joke
I just started
like sobbing convulsively.
So, that -- somebody came around
and was like, are you all right?
Like, what's going on?
I was like I just --
it's a story, there
was a joke [laughter].
And, so, I think -- I think
the two can be played off
against each other in
very effective ways.
>> Gowri K.: We had
a question up here
in this second row, Anne.
>> Okay, this is a question --
well, a comment and
a question for Reese.
So, I was having lunch, and
I'm so glad that you ended
with that comment
about obsession
and your writing
process and how you sort
of wrote everything
over and over again.
And I, as a reader of your work
anyway, really appreciate that.
And I was at lunch today
with a bunch of writers
who actually do crime fiction,
things like that, and I
was talking about how I was
coming to this event tonight
and I was excited and
how it's very short.
But, I feel like you must have
started like an 800-page novel
and then like over eight years
[inaudible] it taken you.
And you had sort of compressed
it down and sort of taken
out every fluff word,
answer taken,
like every eight word sentence
and made it into four words
until it meant the same thing
and carried all the
same emotion,
and just -- but, you made
it into this compressed,
dense thing of emotion and
sort of beauty and rhythm
and that it actually
took me a while
to read just because I was --
just I had to re-read
some of these sentences
because they were
just so magnificent.
So, as a reader, thank
you for taking that time,
and those extra years, I
think, really shows up.
So, anyway, so that's
my comment.
The question is, as far as the
POV of your novel, you know,
like the real chapters I
feel like are, you know,
in sort of straightforward
first person,
and then the Phoebe ones, even
though you get to the place
where she's telling the
story in her own words
through recollection or Will,
but I feel like they're
actually still Will's chapters
and he's interpreting
for us what she,
you know, told him
or a story about her
that he recalls or whatever.
Was that intentional
and have you --
I'm just wondering if anybody
tried to [inaudible] hey,
maybe we should, you know,
like take out that Will filter
and just make it straight
Phoebe or whatever?
I'm just curious.
>> R. O. Kwon: So, as I
mentioned in my reading,
the novel alternates
between three points of view,
cult leader, Phoebe, and Will.
And, in a lot of ways, I don't
think I'm giving too much away
by noting that the
novel does indicate
in a lot of ways
that Will's the one really
telling the whole novel.
And, so, the first two years
the novel was told entirely
from Phoebe's point of view.
And then I realized that, well,
so Phoebe goes through a lot.
Like she -- again, I don't
think I'm giving too much away
by that she loses a
lot and then she sort
of gains a lot in some ways.
And then she -- you know,
like she joins a radical cult
and she is probably involved
in blowing up a building.
Like there's just like --
there's a lot of lived
life experience there.
And it became claustrophobic for
me to remain just in her head.
And I was thinking a lot
about The Great Gatsby
and the Nick Carraway
with the novel [inaudible]
by having him narrate the novel
versus pretty much
anyone else in the book.
He's one of the most least of
all characters in a lot of ways
in these characters' lives.
And, so, I found that when I
stepped aside and let sort of --
and let somebody
who loved Phoebe,
but wasn't involved
very much in the act --
in the sort of main action
of the book, tell the book,
it opened up -- like
it opened up.
It brought air into the room.
It opened up a lot of
sort of space to play.
So, there's that.
The second question about
splitting up the book.
So, I -- this is a question,
and with first person
novels I know a lot
of people don't have
any problem with this,
but I found that I wanted the
novel to have a reason to exist,
even inside of its
own fictional world.
And, so, in some
ways the novel comes
about because Will's trying
to understand what happened,
what happened to this woman he
loved and what happened to him,
what happened to
their relationship.
And, so, that -- and
he's sort of trying to --
he trying to understand.
He's trying to explain it.
And, so, that whole explanation
is -- that attempt is the book.
And, so, the novel -- I
never wanted the novel,
I found I never wanted
the novel to stray outside
of what Will could either know
or imagine about what happened.
And, so, that provided sort
of like a very useful circle
around what was possible.
So, all of this sounds
very intentional.
It wasn't intentional
[laughter].
Like I feel as though
like nothing I did
was [inaudible] choose
or decided [inaudible]
useable word.
It was more like had to happen
after 50,000 revision attempts.
It's like, oh okay, yeah, this
is what was supposed to happen.
>> Gowri K.: I think we have
time for one more question.
Are there?
[Inaudible]?
Now I'm just calling
people by name.
>> Thank you so much to
both of you for being here.
I had a question about
writing [inaudible]
and the actual discipline of
sitting yourself down
and just, you know,
unloading whatever you have
onto the page, the screen.
And I've been trying
to find the balance
between writing discipline
and practice
and self-care, because I
feel like as someone who
grew up in an immigrant home,
I have internalized this idea
that work is a very zero-some
game, or either you're working
and you are strung out,
or you are, if you're not
doing that or some form
of that, then you are lazy.
And I think just trying to
navigate, you know, those values
about work and applying
them to creative life
I found to be kind
of a messy process.
So, I was wondering what each
of you had to say about that.
>> Hieu Minh Nguyen:
I think it's important
to consider it work.
That it's just -- it's not just
like something that we are doing
for fun, but it takes work
and it takes effort and time.
But, also, I think there's a --
I think it also takes like
being kind to yourself
when it's not working out.
I forgot -- oh God.
Okay, this is going
to be so embarrassing.
So, what is -- what is
the name of the woman
who wrote Eat, Pray, Love?
Elizabeth Gilbert.
Well, I was watching one
of her Ted Talks [laughter]
and my friend directed
me to her Ted Talk.
And she talks about in
like, I think it was
like Ancient Greece
they believed
in the spirit of
the genius, right?
And that [inaudible] and artists
weren't actually like geniuses
or whatever, but they had
the spirit of a genius living
in the walls of their studio.
And, so, when they're in
their studio and they're ready
to create, sometimes the genius
would come and use their body
as a vessel to make art.
And then when they're in their
studio and they're unable
to create something,
it's because the genius is
off somewhere else, right?
And, so, that like takes away
the pressure of like I need
to be like this working machine.
I need to be -- or,
something is wrong
with me if I'm not doing it.
Why can't -- why can't I do it?
And I like that idea.
Thank you, Elizabeth
Gilbert [laughter].
I also like the idea of
considering it work, too.
So, the -- so, yeah,
so like there's --
I find like when I
can't create something
that I can edit something,
right,
something that I created before.
And I think that, yeah,
that's part of it.
Like figuring out
where your energy goes
if it can't go towards the
thing you want it to go to.
>> R. O. Kwon: So,
until December I had a very
consistent answer for this,
because I did really write
pretty much every day
for those 10 years.
But, since December I've been
writing so little fiction,
and if I'm not writing fiction
I feel a little dead inside,
so I've been a little dead
inside for a little while.
It's okay.
I soon will get it back.
But, the -- so, until December I
had all kinds of rules in place.
Like I did not have
internet during the day.
I didn't have a flip phone.
I've been borrowing a smartphone
so I could get around
as I travel.
I would not talk to anyone
in the morning before I got
to work, because if I got to
writing because I didn't --
I wanted to go as fast as I can
from my dream state
to my writing.
I wouldn't even eat until I had
gotten like a solid hour of work
or so in, because
like I find food
to be extremely pleasurable,
and that's very distracting
[laughter]
if I'm at home writing.
I -- oh man, all kinds of shit.
But, it's been less
useful lately,
again because I've been doing
all this other kind of stuff,
which I don't regret, but
it's not fiction writing.
And, so, lately I've been taking
-- I'm on the extreme other end
of trying to do things.
Like at the very least on
a given trying to write
for like five minutes
or 10 minutes.
At the very least by trying to
-- at the very least trying --
like if I notice a
word I want to use,
like writing down that word.
And, so just trying to stay in
touch in some way with a part
of myself that loves fiction
and thrives on fiction
and needs fiction to live.
And so, yeah, I feel like
those are two ends of --
two like very different
kinds of ends.
First, there's the [inaudible].
I was -- I was a -- you know,
I was like a hermit in a --
hermit in the room answer,
and then there's the I
barely have time to write.
But, I'm trying.
And I'm trying to stay in touch
with it every day
to the extent I can.
>> Gowri K.: Thank you
all for your question.
Can we please do a round of
applause for [inaudible]?
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Casper:
And thanks also --
thanks also to our
moderator, and thanks to all
of you for coming out.
[ Applause ]
The books are for
sale in the back.
We hope you get some.
We hope you ask for autographs.
And we would love to see you
down the street on
Monday, October 1.
The kickoff for the fall Life of
a Poet series with Ron Charles
from the Washington Post with
Marilyn Chin [assumed spelling].
So, if you're around, it
will be a conversation
that will hopefully be
almost as luminating
as this one this evening.
So, thanks so much
for coming out.
And do get a book
and see you soon.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.